There are many words we could use to describe the 2016 US presidential campaign. To multiverse, divisive, vulgar. Over the past few weeks, we've tried to offer insight into some of the deeper issues underlying all the ranker. We've looked at the hidden frames that shape our political views. If you have two different views of the nation, you may have two different views of the family. An examined the biases that women face when they seek higher office. I came home that night, I was so upset and and and and demeaned to use the word that I thought, okay, that's it, I can't take this anymore, I'm gonna quit.
我们可以用许多词来形容2016年美国总统大选。多元、分裂、粗俗。在过去的几周里，我们试图深入剖析所有这些争吵背后的更深层问题。我们研究了塑造我们政治观点的隐秘框架。如果你对国家有两种不同的看法，你对家庭也可能会有不同的看法。我们还审视了女性在竞选更高职位时所面临的偏见。那天晚上我回到家，感到非常沮丧、难过，用一个词来形容就是受辱，当时我想，够了，我再也受不了了，我要辞职。
We've also talked about topics that have surfaced over and over again in the election. Topics like immigration, income inequality, and stop-and-frisk policing. Today, we'll conclude our series with a favorite episode from our archives. It's about an issue that didn't get much attention during the election, but will surely confront the next administration. Climate change. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantan. Last year my family and I took a vacation to Alaska.
我们还讨论了在这次大选中反复浮现的话题。诸如移民、收入不平等以及截停搜查警务等话题。今天，我们将用档案库中精选的一集来为我们的系列节目画上句号。这一集的主题在选举期间并未受到太多关注，但它必将是下一届政府不得不面对的问题。气候变化。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是香卡·维丹坦。去年，我和家人去阿拉斯加度假。
This was a much needed, long planned break. The best part? I got to walk on the top of a glacier. The pale blue ice was translucent. Sharp ridges opened up into crevices dozens of feet deep. Every geological feature, every hill, every valley was sculpted in ice. It was a sunny day and I spotted a small stream of melted water. I got on the ground and drank some. I wondered how long this water had remained frozen. The little stream is not the only ice that's melting in Alaska.
这是一次期待已久、筹划多时的难得假期。最棒的部分是什么？我得以在冰川顶上步行。淡蓝色的冰体呈半透明状。锋利的冰脊裂开，形成了数十英尺深的冰缝。每一个地质景观、每一座山丘、每一道山谷都是由冰雕琢而成的。那天阳光明媚，我发现了一条细小的融水溪流。我趴在地上喝了一些。我纳闷这水究竟冰冻了多久。这条小溪并不是阿拉斯加唯一正在融化的冰。
The Mendenhall Glacier, one of the chief tourist attractions in Juneau, has retreated over one and a half miles in the last half century. Today you can only see a small sliver of the Glacier's tongue from a look-up. I caught up with John Neary, a forest service official who tries to explain to visitors the scale of the changes that they're witnessing. I would say that right now we're looking at a glacier that's filling up out of our 180 degree view we have. We're looking at maybe glacier that's filling up out of our 180 degree view we have.
门登霍尔冰川是朱诺的主要旅游景点之一，在过去半个世纪里已经退缩了英里半以上。如今，从观景台上只能看到冰川舌的一小部分。我采访了约翰·尼尔利，他是一名林业服务官员，负责向游客解释他们所目睹的变化规模。我想说的是，现在我们看到的冰川，在我们拥有的度视野中。我们看到的可能是度视野中正在填满的冰川。
We're looking at maybe 10 or 15 degrees of it. Whereas if we stood in the same place 100 years ago, it would have filled up about 160 degrees of our view. You are kidding, 160 degrees of our view? Exactly, that's the reality of how big this was. It's been retreating up this valley at about 40 or 50 feet a year, most recently 400 feet of year. And even more dramatically recently is the thinning and the narrowing as it's just sort of collapsed in on itself in the bottom of this valley. Instead of dominating much of the valley and being able to see white eyes out a large portion
我们看到的可能只有度或度。而如果我们在一年前站在同一个地方，它会占据我们视野的大约度。你在开玩笑吧，占我们视野的度？没错，这就是它曾经有多大的现实。它正以每年大约到英尺的速度沿着这条山谷退缩，最近甚至是每年英尺。而最近更引人注目的是它的变薄和变窄，因为它在这条山谷的底部开始自行崩塌。它没有主导大部分山谷，也无法在很大一部分景观中看到白色的冰，
of the landscape, it's now becoming this little ribbon that's at the bottom here. John is a quiet soft-spoken man. In recent years, as he's watched the glacier literally recede before his eyes, he started to speak up. Not just about what's happening, but what it means. But as I was chatting with John, a visitor came up to talk to him. The man said he used to serve in the Air Force and had last seen the Mendenhall Glacier a quarter century ago. There was a look in the man's eyes. It was a combination of awe and horror.
它现在变成了底部的一条小溪。约翰是个安静、轻声细语的人。近年来，当他眼睁睁地看着冰川实实在在地退缩时，他开始发声了。不仅是为了正在发生的事情发声，也是为了探究它的意义。但正当我与约翰交谈时，一位游客走过来和他说话。这个人说他曾在空军服役，上一次看到门登霍尔冰川还是在四分之一世纪前。这个人的眼神中流露出一种神情。那是敬畏与恐惧的交织。
How could this have happened the man asked John? Why is this happening? In many ways people don't want to grasp the reality. It's a scary reality to try to grasp. And so what they naturally want to do is assume, well, this has always happened, it will happen in the future and will survive, won't we? They want an assurance from me. But I don't give it to them.
这怎么可能发生呢？这个人问约翰。为什么会这样？在许多情况下，人们不想面对现实。这是一个让人感到恐惧、难以面对的现实。因此，他们自然而然地想要假设，嗯，这种情况以前发生过，将来也会发生，我们会挺过去的，对吧？他们希望我给他们一个保证。但我没有给他们。
I don't think it's my job to give them that assurance. I think they need to grasp the reality of the fact that we are entering into a time when yes, glacial advance in retreat has happened 25 different times to North America over its long life, but never at the rate and the scale that we see now. And in the very quick rapidity of it means that species probably won't be able to adapt the way that they have in the past over a longer period of time. To be clear, the Mendenhall Glacier's retreat in and of itself is not proof of climate change.
我不认为给予他们这种保证是我的工作。我认为他们需要正视这样一个事实：我们正在进入这样一个时期——是的，北美在其漫长的生命中确实发生过次冰川前进和后退，但其速度和规模是前所未有的。而且如此之快的速度意味着物种可能无法像过去那样在更长的时间内适应这种变化。需要明确的是，门登霍尔冰川的退缩本身并不是气候变化的证据。
That evidence comes from a range of scientific measurements and calculations. But the Glacier is a visible symbol of the changes that scientists are documenting. It's interesting, I think, when people think about climate change, it tends to be an abstract issue most of the time for most people that you're standing in front of this magnificent glacier right now, and to actually see it receding makes it feel real and visceral in a way that it just isn't when I'm living in Washington, D.C. Oh, I agree.
这些证据来自于一系列科学测量和计算。但这座冰川是科学家们正在记录的变化的有形象征。我认为很有意思的是，当人们想到气候变化时，对大多数人来说，它在大多数时间里往往是一个抽象的问题，而你现在正站在这个雄伟的冰川前，亲眼看着它退缩，这让它变得真实而直观，这种感觉是在华盛顿特区生活时所没有的。哦，我同意。
I think that for too many people, the issue is some Micronesian island that's having an extra inch of water this year on their shorelines, or it's some polar bears far up in the Arctic that they're really not connected with. But when they realize they come here, and they're on this nice day, like we're experienced right now with the warm sun, they start to think about this glacier melting
我认为对太多人来说，这个问题不过是某个密克罗尼西亚岛屿今年海岸线上的水多涨了一英寸，或者是远在北极、与他们毫无关联的北极熊。但当他们意识到自己来到这里，在这个像我们现在这样阳光温暖的美好日子里，他们开始思考这座冰川的融化
and why it's receding, why it's disappearing, why it doesn't look like that photo, just 30 years ago up in the visitor center, it becomes real for them and they have to start grapple with the issues behind it. I could see tourists turning these questions over in their minds as they watch the glacier. So even though I had not planned to do any reporting, I started interviewing people using the only device I had available,
以及它为什么在退缩，为什么在消失，为什么它看起来不像访客中心里仅仅三十年前的那张照片那样，这一切对他们来说就变得真实了，他们不得不开始认真对待背后的问题。我看到游客们在观察冰川时，脑海中不断琢磨着这些问题。因此，尽管我本来没打算做任何报道，我还是开始用手头唯一的设备采访人们，
my phone. I just think it's a shame that we are losing something pretty precious and pretty different in the world. This is Dale Singer. She and her family came to Alaska on a cruise to celebrate a couple of family birthdays. This was her second trip to Mendenhall. She came about nine years ago, but the weather was so foggy, she couldn't get a good look. She felt compelled to come back. I asked Dale why she thought the glacier was retreating.
我的手机。我只是觉得，我们正在失去世界上一些非常珍贵、非常独特的东西，这真是一大遗憾。这是戴尔·辛格。她和家人乘游轮来到阿拉斯加，是为了庆祝几个家庭生日。这是她第二次来门登霍尔。她大约九年前来过，但当时雾太大，看不清楚。她觉得非得再来一次不可。我问戴尔为什么她认为冰川在退缩。
Global warming, whether we like to admit it or not, it's our fault or something we're doing is effect and climate change Others are not so sure for some of Dale's fellow passengers on her cruise This is a touchy topic Somebody just said they went to a lecture on the ship and the Lecturer did not use the word global warming nor climate change because he didn't want to offend passengers. So there are still people who refuse to admit it. As I was standing next to John, one man carefully came up and listened to his account of the science of climate change.
全球变暖，不管我们愿不愿意承认，这是我们的错，或者是我们正在做的事情造成的影响和气候变化。其他人则没有那么确定。对戴尔游轮上的某些同伴来说，这是一个敏感的话题。有人刚说他们在船上听了一个讲座，讲师没有使用“全球变暖”或“气候变化”这两个词，因为他不想冒犯乘客。所以仍然有人拒绝承认这一点。正当我站在约翰旁边时，一个男人小心翼翼地走过来，听他讲述关于气候变化科学的解说。
When John was done talking, the man told him that he wouldn't trust scientists as far as he could throw them. Climate change was all about politics, he said. I asked the man for an interview, but he declined. He said his company had contracts with the federal government, and of bureaucrats in the Obama administration heard his skeptical views on climate change, those contracts might mysteriously disappear. I caught up with another tourist. I asked Michael Bull if he believed climate change was real. No, I think there's global climate change, but I question whether it's all due to human interaction with the Earth. Yes, you can't deny the thing that climate is changing.
当约翰讲完时，那个人告诉他，他对科学家的信任度微乎其微。他说，气候变化完全是政治问题。我邀请这位先生接受采访，但他拒绝了。他说他的公司与联邦政府有合同，如果奥巴马政府的官僚们听到他对气候变化的怀疑态度，这些合同可能会神秘地消失。我遇到了另一位游客。我问迈克尔·布尔是否认为气候变化是真实的。不，我认为存在全球气候变化，但我怀疑这是否全都是由于人类与地球的互动引起的。是的，你不能否认气候正在改变这一事实。
But the causation of that, I'm not sold on as being our fault. Michael was worried his tour bus might leave without him, so he answered my question about whether the Glacier's retreat was cause for alarm, standing next to the idling bus. So what's the bad part of the glacier receiving? And you know from what John said to me, if it's the rate at which and the Earth can't adapt, that makes sense to me. But I think the final story is yet to be written. I think Mother Earth pushes back.
但对于其中的因果关系，我并不认为那是我们的错。迈克尔担心他的旅游巴士不等他就开走了，所以他站在怠速运转的巴士旁，回答了我关于冰川退缩是否值得担忧的问题。那么冰川退缩有什么不好呢？你知道的，从约翰对我说的话来看，如果是这种速率而且地球无法适应的话，这对我来说是有道理的。但我认为最终的定论尚未揭晓。我认为大地母亲会进行反击。
So, I don't think we're going to destroy her because I think she'll take care of us before we take care of her. The Waterfall The Waterfall The Waterfall The Waterfall The Waterfall The Waterfall The
所以，我不认为我们会毁灭她，因为我认为在我们照顾她之前，她会先照顾我们。瀑布瀑布瀑布瀑布瀑布瀑布瀑布
Waterfall The Nucket Falls is a beautiful waterfall that empties into Mendenhall Lake. When John first came to Alaska in 1982, the waterfall was adjacent to the glacier. Today, there is a gap of three quarters of a mile between the waterfall and the glacier. The glacier has receded unbelievably. It's quite shocking. This is Sue Schultz. She said she lived in June or back in the 1980s. This was her first time back in 28 years. What did it look like 28 years ago? The bear rock that you see to the left, as you face the glacier, was glacier.
瀑布娜克特瀑布是一个美丽的瀑布，注入门登霍尔湖。约翰于年刚来到阿拉斯加时，瀑布紧邻着冰川。如今，瀑布与冰川之间已有四分之三英里的间隙。冰川退缩得难以置信。这相当令人震惊。这是苏·舒尔茨。她说她在年代曾在朱诺生活过。这是她时隔年第一次回来。年景是什么样子的？面对冰川时，你左边看到的裸露岩石以前都是冰川。
And we used to hike on the other side of it. You could take a trail right onto the glacier. And what about this way? I understand the glacier actually came significantly over to this side close to nugget falls. Yes, that's true. It was really close. In fact, the lake was a lot smaller, obviously. I mean, yeah, it's quite incredible. And so what's your reaction when you see it? Global warming. We need to pay attention. Even if it all melts, it's not going to be the end of the world.
我们以前经常在它的另一边徒步。你可以顺着一条小路直接走到冰川上。那这边呢？我听说冰川实际上明显延伸到了靠近娜克特瀑布的这一侧。是的，确实如此。它离得非常近。事实上，显然湖泊要小得多。我是说，是的，这太不可思议了。那么你看到它时的反应是什么？全球变暖。我们需要予以关注。即使它全部融化了，也不会是世界末日。
So I'm not worried. Terry Lambert is a tourist from Southern California. He's never visited Mendon Hall before. He thinks the melting glacier is just part of nature's plan. While it's just like earthquakes and floods and hurricanes, there are just all part of what's going on. You can't control it, you can't change it. And I personally don't think it's something that man's doing that's making that melt.
所以我不担心。特里·兰伯特是来自南加州的游客。他以前从未参观过门登霍尔。他认为融化的冰川只是大自然计划的一部分。虽然它就像地震、洪水和飓风一样，都只是正在发生的事情的一部分。你无法控制它，你也无法改变它。而且我个人不认为这是人类造成的融化。
I mentioned to Terry some of the possible consequences of climate change on various species. Well, there could be changes species could some species could be advantage, some species could be disadvantage, the ecosystem is changing, you're going to have flooding, you could have weather events, right? There could be consequences that affect you and I. Yes, but like I say it so far in the future, I'm not worried about it. I realized at that moment that the debate over climate change is no longer really about science, unless the science you're talking about is the study of human behavior. I asked John why he thought so many people were unwilling to
我向特里提到了气候变化对各种物种可能产生的一些影响。嗯，可能会有变化，有些物种可能会受益，有些物种可能会受损，生态系统在改变，会有洪水，可能会有天气事件，对吧？可能会产生影响你我的后果。是的，但就像我说的，这太遥远了，我不担心。那一刻我意识到，关于气候变化的争论实际上已不再是关于科学，除非你所说的科学是对人类行为的研究。我问约翰，为什么他认为有那么多人不愿意
accept the scientific consensus that climate change was having real consequences. The inability to do anything about it themselves, because it's threatening to think about giving up your car, giving up your oil heater in your house, or giving up many of the things that you've become accustomed to, they seem very threatening to them. And really, I've looked at some of the brain science actually and talked to folks at NASA and Earth and Sky, and they've actually talked about how, when that fear becomes overriding for people, they use a part of their brain. That's the very primitive part that has to react.
接受关于气候变化会带来实际后果的科学共识。因为他们自己无力对此做任何事情，因为一想到要放弃你的汽车、放弃你家里的燃油暖气，或者放弃你已经习以为常的许多事情，就会让人感到充满威胁，这些对他们来说似乎极具威胁性。说实话，我实际上研究过一些脑科学，并与美国宇航局（）以及“地球与天空”（）的工作人员交流过，他们实际上谈到过，当这种恐惧对人们来说变得压倒一切时，他们会使用大脑的一个部分。那是必须作出反应的非常原始的部分。
It has to instantly come to a conclusion so that it can lead to an action. Whereas what we need to think about is get rid of that fear and start thinking logically, start thinking creatively, allow a different part of the brain to kick in and really think how we as humans can reverse this trend that we've caused. Coming up, we explore why the human brain might not be well designed to grapple with a threat of climate change and what we can do about it. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. While visiting the Mendenhall Glacier with my family last year, I started thinking more and more about the intersection between climate change and human behavior.
它必须瞬间得出结论，以便付诸行动。而我们需要思考的是消除这种恐惧，开始进行逻辑思考，开始进行创造性思考，让大脑的不同部分发挥作用，并真正思考我们人类如何才能扭曲我们所造成的这种趋势。接下来，我们将探讨为什么人类的大脑可能并不适合应对气候变化的威胁，以及我们能对此做些什么。请继续收听。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是香卡·维丹坦。去年我和家人访问门登霍尔冰川时，我开始越来越多地思考气候变化与人类行为之间的交集。
When I got back to Washington DC, I called George Marshall. He's an environmentalist who, like John Neary, tries to educate people about global climate change. I am the founder of Climate Outreach and I am the author of don't even think about it why our brains are wired to ignore climate change. As the book's title suggests George believes that the biggest roadblock in the battle against climate change may lie inside the human brain. I call George at his home in Wales. You spend some time talking with Daniel Kahneman, the famous psychologist who won the Nobel Prize in Economics, and he actually presented a very pessimistic view that we would actually
当我回到华盛顿特区后，我打电话给乔治·马歇尔。他是一位环保主义者，和约翰·尼尔利一样，致力于向人们普及全球气候变化的知识。我是气候 outreach 的创始人，也是《想都别想：为什么我们的大脑生来就会忽视气候变化》一书的作者。正如书名所示，乔治相信对抗气候变化道路上的最大绊脚石可能就存在于人类大脑内部。我在他在威尔士的家中给他打了电话。你曾花时间与丹尼尔·卡尼曼交谈过，这位获得诺贝尔经济学奖的著名心理学家，他实际上提出了一个非常悲观的观点，即我们是否会
come to terms with the threat of climate change. He said to me that we are as humans, very poor at dealing with issues, whether in the future we tend to be very focused on a short term. We tend to discount, would be the economic term, to reduce the value of things happening in the future of a further away they are. He says we're very cost-averse, that's to say, when there is a reward we respond strongly but when there is a cost we prefer to push it away just as I myself would try and leave until the very last minute, you have been in my tax return, I mean you just don't want
正视气候变化的威胁。他对我说，作为人类，我们在处理问题时非常糟糕，无论是在未来，我们往往高度关注短期。用经济学的术语来说，我们往往会打折，即降低未来发生的事情的价值，它们越遥远就越贬值。他说我们非常厌恶成本，也就是说，当有回报时我们的反应很强烈，但当有代价时我们更倾向于把它推开，就像我自己会试图拖到最后一分钟才报税一样，我的意思是，你就是不想
to deal with these things. And he says, well we're reluctant to deal with uncertainty. If things are uncertain, we, or we perceive them to be, we just say, well come back and tell me when they're certain. What he said to me was in his view that climate change is the worst possible combination, because it's not only in the future, but it's also in the future and uncertain, and it's in the future uncertain and involving costs. And his own experiments, and he's done many, many of these over the years, show that in this combination,
去处理这些事情。他说，嗯，我们不愿意处理不确定性。如果事情是不确定的，我们，或者我们认为它们是不确定的，我们就会说，好吧，等确定了再来告诉我。他对我说，在他看来，气候变化是最糟糕的组合，因为它不仅发生在未来，而且还在未来且充满不确定性，并且发生在未来、充满不确定性且涉及成本。他自己的实验——这些年来他做过非常非常多的实验——表明在这种组合下，
we have a very strong tendency just to push things on one side. And I think this in some ways explains how, so many people, if you ask them, we'll say, yes, I regard climate change to be a threat. But if you go and you ask them them and this happens every year in surveys, what are the most important issues, what are the strangely almost everybody seems to forget about climate change. So when we focus on it, we know it's there, but we can somehow push it away.
我们有一种非常强烈的倾向，就是把事情放到一边。我认为这在某种程度上解释了为什么有那么多人在被问及时代会说，是的，我认为气候变化是一个威胁。但如果你去问他们——这在每年的民意调查中都会发生——哪些是最重要的问题，奇怪的是几乎所有人似乎都把气候变化忘得精光。所以当我们关注它时，我们知道它在那里，但我们不知怎么地能把它推开。
You tell an amusing story in your book about some colleagues who are worried about a cell phone tower being erected in their neighborhood and the very very different reaction of these colleagues to the cell phone tower then to sort of the amorphous threat of climate change. They were my neighbors my entire community I was living at that time in Oxford, which is many of your listeners know is a university town so I'd be like living in you know Harvard or Berkeley or somewhere where most of the people were in various ways involved in the university, highly educated, a mobile phone, a master was being set up in the middle. Alongside actually a school playground, a enormous outcry, everybody mobilized down the local church hall, they were all going
你在书中有趣地讲了一个故事，关于一些同事担心他们社区里要竖起一座手机发射塔，以及这些同事对这座手机发射塔的反应，与对气候变化那种无定形威胁的反应截然不同。他们是我的邻居，整个社区的人。我当时住在牛津，正如你们的许多听众所知，那是一个大学城，所以这就有点像住在哈佛或伯克利之类的地方，那里大多数人以各种方式与大学有关，受过高等教育，一个移动电话发射塔要在中间建立起来。而且实际上就在一所学校操场旁边，引起了巨大的抗议，每个人都动员起来去当地的教堂大厅，他们都要
to stop it, people even going to lay themselves down in front of a bulldozer to prevent it. Because it was here, it was now. There was an enemy which was this external mobile phone company. We're going to come in there. We're going to put up this mast. It brings in the threat psychologists would call the absolute fear of radiation. This is what's called a dread fear. And so on.
去阻止它，人们甚至要躺在推土机前面来阻止它。因为它就在这里，就在此时此地。有一个敌人，就是这个外部的移动电话公司。我们要进去了。我们要竖起这个发射塔。它带来了心理学家所称的绝对辐射恐惧的威胁。这就是所谓的恐惧。等等。
The science, if we go back to the core science, says that this mobile phone mask was, as far as we could possibly say harmless, the amount of radiation or any kind, you get off a single mobile phone mask, has never been found to have the slightest impact on anyone, but they were very mobilized. At the same time, I was trying to get them to attend events concerned of climate change
科学，如果我们回到核心科学，表明这个移动电话发射塔，就我们所能确定的而言是无害的，你从单个移动电话发射塔受到的任何辐射或任何种类的辐射，从未被发现对任何人产生过丝毫影响，但他们被极大地动员起来了。与此同时，我试图让他们参加与气候变化有关的活动，
and none of them would come. It simply didn't have those qualities. You have a very revealing anecdote in your book about the economist Thomas Shelling, who was once in a major traffic jam. So, Shellinger, again, Nobel Prize winning economist, and he's wondering what's going on. The traffic is moving very, very, very slowly, and then they're creeping along, and creeping along, and half an hour along the road.
而他们谁也不肯来。它根本不具备那些特质。你的书里有一个非常发人深省的轶事，关于经济学家托马斯·谢林，他曾经遇上了一场大堵车。所以，谢林，同样是获得诺贝尔奖的经济学家，他在纳闷发生了什么。交通走得非常非常非常慢，然后他们缓缓蠕动，缓缓蠕动，在路上开了半个小时。
They finally realize what has happened, that there's a mattress lying right in the middle of the, the middle lane of the road. What happens, he notices, and he does the same, is when they reach for mattress, people will simply drive, pass it, and keep going. In other words, the thing that caused them to become delayed was not something that anyone was prepared to stop and remove from the road. They just leave the mattress there, and then they keep driving past.
他们终于意识到发生了什么，原来路中间，路中间的车道上躺着一个床垫。他注意到，而且他自己也是这么做的，当他们到达床垫旁边时，人们会直接开车从旁驶过，继续前行。换句话说，导致他们延误的东西并不是任何准备停下来把它从路上移开的东西。他们只是把床垫留在那里，然后继续开车从旁边驶过。
Because in a way, why would they remove the mattress from the road because they have already paid the price of getting there, they've already had the delay? It's something where the benefit goes to other people. The argument being, but of course it's very hard, especially when people are motivated largely through personal rewards to get them to do things. It's interesting that the same narrative affects the way we talk about climate change internationally. There are many countries who now say, look, I've already paid the price. I'm paying the price right now for the actions of other people, for the things that other
因为从某种意义上说，他们为什么要从路上移开床垫呢，因为他们已经付出了到达那里的代价，他们已经遭遇了延误？这是一个好处归于其他人的事情。争论的焦点是，当然这非常困难，特别是当人们主要受到个人回报的驱动来让他们做事情时。有趣的是，同样的叙事也影响了我们国际上讨论气候变化的方式。现在有许多国家说，听着，我已经付出了代价。我正在为其他人的行为、为其他人已经做过或未做过的事情付出代价。我正在承担这个成本。你现在要求我下车，把床垫从路上移开，去承担额外的成本，而唯一从中受益的人不是我。集体问题最终会产生个人的后果。我必须说，谈论这件事的方式也表明了这种解读是如何被你自己的政治立场或你自己的观点所左右的。长期以来，这被贴上了“公地悲剧”的标签。
people have or have not done. I'm bearing that cost. You're asking me now to get out of my car, pull the mattress off the road to bear an additional cost, and the only people who benefit from that are people who are not me. The collective problems in the end have personal consequences. I have to say that the way that one talks about this also shows the way that interpretation is biased by your own politics or your own view. This has been labeled for a long time the tragedy of the commons.
这个概念的意思是，除非出于自身的切身利益，否则人们会摧毁维持他们生存的东西，因为如果他们看不到别人也在做，做这件事就不符合他们的个人利益。在某种程度上这是可以理解的，但当然，这取决于这样一种世界观：你认为人们完全是由他们自己的个人回报所驱动的。我们经常知道，人们是由他们的身份认同感和归属感所驱动的，我们非常清楚，尤其是在重大冲突或战争时期，人们准备做出巨大的个人牺牲，他们从中个人得不到任何东西，只有损失，但他们做出这种牺牲
The idea being that unless people will, if it's in their own self interest, destroy the very thing that sustains them because it's not in their personal interest to do something if they don't see other people doing it. In a way it's understandable, but of course, that depends on a view of a world where you see people has been motivated entirely by their own personal rewards. We often know that people are motivated by their sense of identity and their sense of belonging, and we know very well, not least of all in times of major conflicts or war that people are prepared to make enormous personal sacrifices, from which they personally derive nothing except loss, but they're making that
是为了更大的利益。长期以来，在气候变化问题上，我们犯了一个错误，即完全从经济角度来谈论它。经济成本是多少，经济效益是多少，我们现在仍然这样做，但当然，我们想要对此采取行动的真正动机是我们想要保卫这个世界，保卫我们在这个世界上关心、我们所爱的事物，我们希望为了我们自己以及为了即将到来的人们这样做。所以，乔治，生活中显然有一个领域，你可以看到人们不断把这些神圣的价值置于他们的自私利益之上。你知道，我在这里想到的是我们在世界上拥有的许许多多宗教，它们让人类做出各种经济学家会说不符合他们理性自私利益的事情。
in the interests of the greater good. For a long time with climate change, we've made a mistake of talking about this solely in terms of something which is economic. What of the economic costs and what of the economic benefits, and we still do this, but of course really for motivations for why we want to act on this is what we want to defend the world what we care about in the world we love and we want to do so for ourselves and for the people who are going to come. So George there obviously is one domain in life where you can see people constantly placing these sacred values above their selfish self-interest. You know, I'm thinking here about the many, many religions we have in the world that get people to do all kinds of things that an economist would say is not in their rational self-interest.
人们放弃食物，人们放弃水，人们，你知道的，遭受巨大的个人剥夺，人们有时选择终身守贞。我的意思是，这是人们愿意承担的巨大代价，他们这样做并不是因为有人在年底说，我要在你的工资支票里多给你两百美元或者多给你两千美元。他们这样做是因为他们相信这些是不容妥协的神圣价值。不，不仅是经济学家会觉得这些——不，不仅是经济学家会觉得这些行为很奇怪，而且卡尼曼教授或某种纯粹的认知心理学可能也会觉得奇怪，因为这些人正在与长期来看极其不确定且需要付出个人代价的事物作斗争，但同时也对这些事物坚信不疑。
People give up food, people give up water, people have, you know, suffer enormous personal privations, people sometimes choose chastity for life. I mean, huge costs that people are willing to bear, and they're not doing it because someone says at the end of the year, I'm going to give you an extra 200 bucks in your paycheck or an extra $2,000 in your paycheck. They're doing it because they believe these are sacred values that are not negotiable. No, and not just economists would find those And not just economists would find those behaviors strange, but Professor Karlamon or kind of pure cognitive psychology might as well, because these are people who are struggling with but also believe passionately in things which are in the long term extremely uncertain
然而人们还是这么做了。非常重要的一点是要强调，当我们谈论气候变化与宗教时，绝对没有任何迹象表明气候变化现在是、能够或者应该永远像一种宗教，它不是，它扎根于科学。但我认为，我们也可以从宗教那里学到很多东西，关于如何对待这些问题、这些不确定问题，以及如何建立一个我认为由共同信念和共同确信组成的社区，即某事是重要的。
and require personal cost. And yet people do so. It's very important to stress that when we talk about climate change and religion that there's absolutely no sense at all that climate change is or can or should ever be like a religion, it's not, it's grounded in science. But we can also learn, I think, a great deal from religions about how to approach these issues, these uncertain issues and how to create, I think, a community of shared belief and shared conviction that something is important.
对。我是说，如果你以宏观的眼光来看待人类历史，你其实不需要是一个有宗教信仰的人去承认宗教在数千年来数百万人的生活中发挥了非常非常重要的作用。如果它确实如此，那么科学的方法就会说，宗教信仰的本质或宗教的实践中存在着某种东西，它利用了我们大脑所能容纳的东西，利用了我们成为部落一部分的渴望，利用了我们与比我们自己更深邃、更宏大的价值观联系在一起的渴望，利用了我们在某种程度上为同胞做事的渴望，
Right. I mean, if you look at human history with sort of the broad view, you don't actually have to be a religious person to acknowledge that religion has played a very, very important role in the lives of millions of people over thousands of years. And if it's done so, then a scientific approach would say there is something about the nature of religious belief or the practice of religion that harnesses what our brains can accommodate, that the harness are yearning to be part of a tribe, are yearning to be connected to deeper and grander values than ourselves, our yearning in some ways to do things for our fellow person in a
这种事在此时此地可能并非有形的，但正如你所说，它实际上可能会带来回报，不仅是为了未来的世代，甚至在来世也是如此。嗯，那些占主导地位的信仰，世界上最强大的这半打信仰，正是最擅长做这件事的信仰。气候变化存在一个巨大的错误，因为它源于科学，但我们假设它不知何故会自动浸入我们心中。很明显，只是用越来越多、越来越多的数据和图表去猛击人们的大脑是行不通的。在我的网络订阅源上，我关注了所有主要的科学订阅源，每天都有一篇新论文说它不仅很糟糕，而且比我们想象的还要糟糕，
way that might not be tangible in the here and now, but might actually pay off, as you say, not just for future generations, but even in the hereafter. Well, and the faiths that dominate, the half a dozen faiths which are the strongest ones in the world are the ones that have been best at doing that. There's a big mistake with climate change because it comes from science, but we assume it just somehow soaks into us. It's very clear that just hitting people over their head with more and more and more data and graphs isn't working. On my internet feeds, I'm on all of the main scientific feeds, there is a new paper every day that says that not only is it bad, but it's worse
而且极其极其严重。实际上严重到我们甚至很难找到词语来描述它。这并不能打动人们，事实上，它往往会把他们推开。然而，如果我们能理解还有其他东西将我们联系在一起，我认为我们可以找到新的语言。我也认为非常重要的一点是要认识到，围绕气候变化的裂痕是社会的，而非科学的。它们是社会和政治的，决定你是否接受它的最主要因素是你的政治价值观。
than we thought, and it's extremely, extremely serious. So serious, actually, we're finding it very hard even to find the words to describe it. That doesn't move people, in fact, actually it tends to push them away. However, if we can understand that there are other things which bind us together, I think that we can find new language. I think it's also very important to recognize that the divides around climate change are social, not scientific. They're social and political, that the single biggest determinants of whether you accept it or you don't accept it is your political values.
这表明应对这一问题的解决方案不是科学，或许是心理学，它们是文化的。我们必须找到表达确信的方式。我们在政治上会有分歧，但我们有共同关心的事物，这些事物必将把我们团结在一起。乔治·马歇尔是《想都别想：为什么我们的大脑生来就会忽视气候变化》一书的作者。
And that suggests for the solutions to this, not scientific, maybe psychology, they are cultural. We have to find ways of saying sure. We're going to disagree on things politically, but we have things in common that we all care about that are going to have to bring us together. George Marshall is the author of Don't Even Think About It. Why are brains are wired to ignore climate change?
乔治，谢谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。不用客气。我很享受。谢谢。本期“隐藏的大脑”由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉辛、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克·内斯特拉克制作。我们的团队成员包括珍妮·施密特、蕾妮·克拉克和塔拉·博伊尔。本周我们的无名英雄是劳伦·埃姆里。几年前我在达拉斯遇到了劳伦。
George, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. You're very welcome. I enjoyed it. Thank you. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Karam Agar Kalasin, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. Our staff includes Jenny Schmidt, Renee Clark and Tara Boyle. This week our unsung hero is Lauren Embry. I met Lauren a couple of years ago in Dallas.
我很快了解到她对社会科学研究有着浓厚的兴趣，尤其是在它应用于社会公正问题方面。劳伦和埃姆里家族基金会是“隐藏的大脑”项目的早期支持者，他们提供了最早的一批资金，让这个播客得以起步。如果你喜欢“隐藏的大脑”，你得感谢劳伦。我们也是。想了解更多“隐藏的大脑”内容，请在脸书和推特上关注我们。如果你喜欢我们关于总统大选的系列节目，请告诉一位还不知道我们节目的朋友。
I quickly learned she has a deep ago in Dallas. I quickly learned she has a deep interest in social science research, especially as it applies to social justice issues. Lauren and the Embry Family Foundation were early backers of the Hidden Brain project, and they provided some of the first dollars that got this podcast off the ground. If you like Hidden Brain, you have Lauren to thank. As do we. For more Hidden Brain, follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked our series about the presidential election, please tell one friend who doesn't yet know about our show.
你可以在网站上以及你当地的公共广播电台找到我们的更多报道。我是香卡·维丹坦，这里是全国公共广播电台。本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
You can find more of our reporting at npr.org and on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在 npr.org 以及您的当地公共广播电台找到我们的更多报道。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这是 NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。